[Music]
who likes massages
me i miss massages massages
ah everything's closed down from an
angry thai lady man
the thing cool to get massage from your
partner but
we ain't professionals you know what i'm
saying that's true
it doesn't go as long you know what that
one hour the love is there
but the hands techniques are it's not
there no
the hurt isn't there it hurts not their
gun has been a nice like
in between one of those true but i like
the human touch too i like i like them
finding the knots like them looking for
it is really like comforting and then
it's like they find it they're like
bam oh oh and it's gone it's like oh
yeah
daragon does not do that and i just like
the spa experience mm-hmm
i need a korean auntie which spot do you
go to i got different ones
he's trying to put himself on blast and
people go check them out
i'm sure true i go to some different
ones
special ones i do some korean ones and i
also do some russian ones
russian that's why you're keeping on the
download
yeah yeah yeah yeah i want to go to some
restaurants yeah what is that like a
russian massage
that's cool it's like you know they can
hit you with the tree branches and
there's like they hit you with trees
russia
they get your your your level up your
the temperature your skin up so that
your circulation goes good
oh okay a lot of rushing that's some
guys up in there
but also it's cool because their their
co-ed areas are are
i mean their areas are co-ed you know
the russian korean places are like yeah
are you nude
no you don't you can't be fully new but
you can at least like be in the hot tub
hot tub swimming pool and we have like
swimming
bathing suit on yeah that's pretty cool
all right i gotta check out one we'll go
we'll go when soon it's open we'll do a
russian baseball
is it in glendale no okay so west
hollywood okay i'm not gonna tell
anything
all right so um i guess just like the
russian massages
that are top secret here in la um
there is a very secretive
on the download type of tradition in the
massaging world
that was it's 200 2 000 years old in
china is it called the happy ending yeah
that's what i'm thinking
it's a down low it's not down low it's
on the download
only because it's intimidating and it's
not a happy ending
is it the freaking ear [ __ ] where
they [ __ ] pop your ear
no so they they use tree branches
in the russian massage yeah yeah so this
particular style of massaging that is
from china
is bamboo not bamboo what is what is the
um the the favorite weapon of uh
chinese gangster nunchucks uh butcher
knife butcher knife
a cleaver creeper a cleaver they're
gonna cleave you what the [ __ ] the back
side of the cleaver
i know the back side would you do this
massage they're going to treat you like
[ __ ] pet king ducks
face
it's called uh the knife massage ah i'm
good
wow i'll skip it but they do so you keep
gotta be sharp though because i mean
they could do that without sharpening
the knife
true true and they are blunt to be clear
they are they're
they're slightly blunted slightly i mean
i mean it's still a blade i mean it's
still like if they wanted to
it's basically like doing this action
with with the cleaver right
yes yeah it's this this the side of your
pocket lady was saying because of the
weight and the way it's
like balanced um it's really easy for
them to apply a lot of pressure
without straining the lady yeah so they
can do it they could do it
for example oh i want to try it yeah
that's a cool thing but i actually i
prefer when they get in
you like their fingers yeah well they
argue that the blade the the thinness of
the blade and like you know different
parts of the blade like the the pointed
part too
they could they can use that to get into
those really
hard to get areas that a finger couldn't
get to i'm not big on the hard massage
either
i like it's moderate but then i want to
have tears come out of my eyes
do you ever get that where it [ __ ] you
up so hard your [ __ ] tear comes out
and you're like
you [ __ ] and then afterwards massage
that made me cry
in hong kong that [ __ ] was painful i'm
like
yeah it's like it's like ticklish and
it's also painful at the same time right
i mean it's the worst combination of
caressed me too
i just dude for me the perfect massage
is just them doing this
this one i was gonna massage one time i
don't know what was happening but then
the woman started like running her
fingers through my hair oh [ __ ]
oh was it like a scalp massage it was a
back massage but then the
then the fingers dragging off their hair
and then she was calm down kind of
holding my hand
oh [ __ ] how was your hand about i'm like
was she doing one of these she was like
doing this and then she started like and
then just became like a hand hole and i
was just like
did you take a breath you're just like i
don't know if i should move i think i'm
just going to pretend like i'm sleeping
for a while i don't know what to do
you got weirded out i was like this is
the russian is that the russian spot
you know what a good one is is when they
[ __ ] do this thing and then you start
doing like a robot
and you're like what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you're controlling my hand
the crazy one is that tie the thai
massage and then they stand on you old
ladies just
break your ass they're just like you
break your ass yeah they're like
what they like basically it's like you
working out but you're not working out
they're working your body yeah
i actually got so sore after a time
she's like bending all her place
i think she she hadn't both my legs up
in the air was like [ __ ] me up i was
like what are you doing
i think you're raping me older thai lady
i've had one where they [ __ ] put my
ankles all the way back right there and
i almost farted
yeah i've had that i had the shimmer i
can imagine the bubble going in and out
of your butt
i'm like oh no oh [ __ ]
i told this girl like i don't really
like feet so i don't i don't want your
feet all over me and stuff
and she's like yeah yeah and the next
thing i know she got like lotion on her
feet and on her back
her foot was all over my face and i
started cracking up and she was cracking
up like this chick don't care about it
is she even oh
customer service you didn't understand
what you said
i don't care about my toes this is how i
do my [ __ ]
her nails all [ __ ] up her whole
routine she didn't know how to skip it
she's just so used to the routine man
one time i was at the korean spa and
then the [ __ ] auntie did that [ __ ]
and my whole back smell like feet dude
shut the [ __ ] up then she went through
her sock i was like
thank god there's a bathtub right here
dude wow
it smelled like [ __ ] like like
like runner's feet you know what i mean
yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] they never
actually step on me because i think
they're scared they're gonna hurt me or
something because
i guess i'm like too small so i'm glad
i've never experienced well i get the
sport
shiatsu or whatever maybe it's the type
two because
you could get like five different kinds
and then my favorite [ __ ] is when they
stand and put their heel
on your ass oh that feels good they got
that little rope on top yeah
and then they [ __ ] spread your ass
cheap rope on top and they'd be holding
on this rope and
kid yeah cause like one time we got a
couple's thai massage and they were
stepping on him but it's not you
oh she's like i'm a break this way why
do they step on your i mean why do they
spread your ass
no they do this thing where it's like so
imagine like this is their feet right
and then they slide it out like that and
it feels like my ass is getting slid
like this yeah and then they go pop
and then they get back on yeah i mean
she had my legs up in the air
for sure do you guys ever have like this
one part of your body that when they go
over it your body involuntarily like
[ __ ] twitches because like especially
around my ass
like every time like they go over my ass
like my my ass cheek just
tenses up by itself like i don't do it
but it's like when you it's like when
you when you
pet your dog in that one spot in their
leg and then they
start melting on you yeah i miss
massages me too yeah so this
uh they call it dao liao it's like
dao is is his knife and the the liao
part i'm not too sure they didn't really
define
maybe i don't know i don't think so so
they're like chopping up duck and then
they come over to you they are hustlers
yeah so the way it works is um the the
cleavers they're
they're blunted they're they're not uh
sharp so they won't cut through anything
you know at least with the pressure that
they're using and they do it over your
clothes or you're supposed to keep your
clothes on and they drape and tell on
top of that to further pad
the massage so it's it's relatively safe
but they do say
that you're not supposed to just start
practicing it like you have to be
trained
by their association they have like uh
the knife association
they have like an actual logo must be
sick it must be like two
yeah two knives like this are they
chopped titties and [ __ ] too like
titties and dick yeah cause these get
tense here
like now i let no one shopping like a
happy ending with a knife massage
[ __ ] that that's scary but yeah so it's
like 2 000 years old and it was
invented in china and this is outside of
the
1000 years old yeah this is outside the
traditional chinese medicine
like like concepts like the chinese how
did they do
even traditional chinese medicine people
are like no no no no no that doesn't
belong in our thing like that that's
like
its own like you know like use your
hands did they i wonder
like when they they first came out with
this like how did they do it back in the
day
with a sheet too or like that i don't
know i can see it cause we all
everyone whenever you're gonna give
someone a massage you you do the knife
hand thing so
sooner or later someone just be like get
the damn get the actual knife yeah and
it's like weighted like you're saying
like it's
maybe that's a result of the cleavers or
maybe yeah who was imitating oh
maybe you might be right you might be
true
but yeah so and then were they cooks
first or the massage people first
cleaver was invented for the massage
cleaver
i don't use it that much in the house
but i i want to use it more
true it's hard to use on things that you
don't need like if you get like a potato
right what's it for when you whack it
then the potato just
flies off the table onto the ground yeah
what's it for well
i think in a chinese kitchen they use it
for everything it's their french knife
it's like they're
everything nice you can [ __ ] peel the
pear with it or they'll
chop i can't do [ __ ] with that knife you
know what looks dope though is when they
have a
tree stump cutting board and it's like a
big [ __ ] it's like a foot
yeah and it's just stuck in there or
like they chopped like
big ass bones and [ __ ] with it dude i
used to chop up
onions with it and i used to [ __ ] my
knuckles up
because well you put your knuckles in
there too cause i know cause like they
were trying to teach me how to do it by
like holding gripping it like the bear
claw so i'm like trying to do it
i get i get a little too brave and you
go a little too fast that's what
happened that's why i [ __ ] my knuckles
up
no i got that chopper you put it in
there and you just
that's right there you go that
[ __ ] dices it up you're like i'm
good
you can put a tomato and an onion at the
same time but i got some global knives
that are like real
sharp that's tight they scare me like
cuts too good you're like i'm gonna [ __ ]
myself
up dude i've done that [ __ ] i've cut my
knuckle until this day i can't fold it
the whole way
what that cause it was just like that
like what you described like it's just
so
smooth it just kind of cuts through
everything you're like oh [ __ ] that's my
hand
i'm so scared of cutting [ __ ] up but
yeah if you want to try this knife
massage
it's making a huge comeback in taiwan
right now it's for
1200 taiwanese dollars or 40 american
dollars
you could get an uh massage for an hour
i'm going to try it looks safe
40 bucks ain't bad yeah i wouldn't try
it for now do they have the
fish that suck on your feet while you
get the chopped on your back that would
be a
nice like have your hands dipped in some
water too at the same time
they could put this in also like in the
in the action film
where you're getting a um massage but
then actually film turns into as a
killer oh hell yeah you gotta
change it get the sharp knife yeah then
you have a whole big
butcher knife fight that's tight i like
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you